This is Sara Blakely and at age 27, she took
$5,000 dollars and turned it into more than
a billion.
She did this by selling a new type of underwear
called Spanx, but her strategy was unlike
any other entrepreneur.
Mark Zuckerberg owns 30% of Facebook.
Elon Musk owns just 20% of Tesla, but Sara
Blakely, she owns 100% of Spanx.
So what does Sara know that Elon and Zuck
don’t?
Most entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley raise
money at some point, and once they start raising
money, it becomes a self-perpetuating cycle.
One round leads to the next, and pretty soon
even the best founders only own a fraction
of their business.
But Sara discovered an alternative strategy
that every entrepreneur should pay attention
to, whether or not you plan on raising money
for your business.
If you were to ask Sara how she became a billionaire
without ever selling a single share of her
company’s stock, she would probably give
you a simple answer like this:
“I don’t know if it was a super conscious
decision along the way, more than I just didn’t
really have the need to.
Spanx was profitable from the first month
I was in business, I’m of the belief system,
for me to start small, think big, and scale
fast...”
But clearly if it were that easy, everyone
would do it, so there has to be more going
on here.
Sara often gets ignored by mainstream business
news precisely because she never raised venture
funding.
Most reporters only write stories about companies
when they announce a big funding round or
go public, but Spanx has just been growing
quietly for two decades now.
And it’s too bad more people don’t focus
on Sara’s story because her initial idea
for Spanx follows the exact same pattern that
so many Silicon Valley investors preach: “Solve
a problem you yourself have.”
“I started Spanx as a frustrated consumer,
I simply wanted to wear white pants to a party
and have nothing show underneath it.
My first product was footless pantihose.
I took a product that already existed and
made a modification, I cut the feet out of
pantihose.”
Solving a problem for yourself is core to
so many great startup ideas.
In fact, “Make something people want”
is the motto of Y Combinator.
But lots of entrepreneurs follow this advice
and don’t become billionaires.
Sara clearly has a secret formula for success,
so I listened to everything she’s ever said
publicly and boiled down her growth strategy
to 3 key factors.
Let’s go through them one at a time.
When most people first come up with a startup
idea, they think they’ve struck gold.
It’s common to think that the idea is the
hardest part, and once you have a good idea,
you need to protect it at all costs, but this
is actually a complete misconception.
Execution is everything in entrepreneurship
and great ideas don’t matter at all if you
can’t make the idea a reality and then distribute
it effectively.
When Sara first came up with the idea for
Spanx, she kept the idea a secret for a year
and even patented the design before launching
the company.
This flies in the face of most traditional
thinking in Silicon Valley.
Any investor will tell you to go out and build
something to make sure there is a market before
working on time consuming things like patents,
but Sara saw things very differently, and
this is factor number one: Sara sees patents
as marketing.
Legally speaking, a patent is a government
license that gives the inventor exclusive
rights to a design for 20 years.
It’s generally a way to stop people from
copying you, but Sara has never sued anyone
for copying Spanx design, instead, she focused
on using the patent as a way to build trust
in her consumers mind.
“I knew that I was patenting this to mostly
to be able to show the value and use it as
a marketing tool.
I was mostly trying to convey, this is new,
this is different”
The U.S. Patent system has become massively
bloated with dozens of patents for slight
variations on the same idea.
And there is now a huge industry of patent
trolls who’s only business is buying patents
and then suing companies who might be infringing
even slightly.
Sara recognized that, even though the patent
system wasn’t working as intended anymore,
it could still be used to her advantage.
Spanx customers would be drawn in by the “patent-pending”
label and investigate the product more thoroughly,
which would lead to purchases.
At my last company, Soylent, we took the opposite
approach, sharing our formulas publicly and
“open-sourcing” our ingredients.
But the overarching goal was actually the
same.
We were doing this for marketing reasons.
By branding ourselves as the one health food
company that was completely open about how
we made our products, we won over consumers
who were hesitant to try Soylent themselves.
The big takeaway here is that, as an entrepreneur,
you need to be flexible while assessing opportunities.
Even though patents may not protect you fully,
the decision to patent could still have an
impact on your business.
The key is to understand that getting a patent
is not a significant milestone in building
your business, only making a great product
and growing your customer base is significant.
I can’t tell you how many venture capitalists
have told me funny stories about crazy inventors
walking into their offices thinking that they
had a great business just because they got
a patent.
There is so much more to growing a business
than thinking of an idea and filing some paperwork
to the US patent office, but Sara understands
that completely, and that leads to her second
key success factor.
Once you’ve actually developed a product,
you need to be able to sell it, and Sara is
a master of selling products.
This makes sense, because she has a background
in sales.
Before she started Spanx, she went door to
door selling fax machines and she learned
a ton of valuable skills during that time.
It’s really common for entrepreneurs to
forget about the importance of sales and marketing
when they come from technology backgrounds.
This was certainly the case for me when I
first moved to Silicon Valley.
I thought that marketing was unnecessary if
you had a good product and generally thought
salespeople were just paid to socialize.
But the best salespeople are actually masters
of human psychology.
The thing about psychology is that it can
be very counterintuitive at times.
For example, most entrepreneurs think that
the best strategy is always to make a better
product and sell it at a lower price, but
that’s not always the case.
See, back when Sara was selling fax machines
door to door, she wasn’t working for Canon,
which was the most popular brand at the time.
She was selling a cheaper machine called a
Dex, and customers weren’t really giving
her the time of day.
But then she discovered something incredible
about the way people think about price and
quality:
“So then I made the price of my Dex slightly
higher than the canon and everybody stopped
in my meetings and started asking more questions
and saying “Why is this Dex more money than
the canon what am I missing” and it gave
me the opportunity to really sell the features
and what was so special about the Dex fax
machine.
And people started buying”
This is the type of thing you would never
learn if you were entirely focused on your
product.
At a certain point, you have to go and interact
with customers in order to see how they actually
behave.
It might surprise you!
Sara used everything she learned selling door
to door to grow Spanx at the early stage.
And it worked!
Lots of entrepreneurs confuse sales with advertising,
but they are actually two completely different
things.
Spanx didn’t advertise, at all, for years,
but that doesn’t mean Sara wasn’t laser
focused on sales.
She called department stores and pitched directly
to buyers, never taking no for an answer.
Her product was solid, but it was really her
ability to convince retailers to take a chance
on Spanx that set her apart from the competition.
Today, it’s common for startups to raise
money and instantly start spending that cash
on facebook ads, but that can be a big mistake.
Instead of seeing paid advertising as the
only route to growth, try and broaden your
horizons and think of all the ways you could
reach your potential customer.
The more you do as an individual entrepreneur,
the more you’ll learn about your customer
and be able to tailor your sales pitch to
fit your specific market.
Sara’s determination didn’t stop once
she got a yes from a retailer though.
She would personally visit every store that
carried Spanx to make sure that her product
was in the optimal part of the store.
No one is going to buy your product if it’s
sitting on the bottom of the shelf at the
back of the store.
You want to be near the entrance or the cash
register so everyone sees it!
Sara knew this and she wouldn’t accept anything
less than best possible placement for Spanx.
She was so bold in fact, that she once got
caught on security cameras personally moving
her product to a better section of the store
without telling management.
But sometimes that’s what it takes to get
ahead of the competition.
This is a big part of sales that often gets
overlooked, and it comes back to human psychology
again.
Convincing someone to buy your product for
their store is just the first step in actually
growing your business.
Plenty of people can be persuaded in a one-on-one
conversation, only to lose interest the next
day.
Great entrepreneurs know that, even after
they win a customer, they have to work extra
hard to keep that customer happy and make
sure the relationship doesn’t fizzle out.
Sara’s hard work paid off and Spanx started
flying off shelves and then she got a huge
break.
She was invited on Oprah and got to pitch
Spanx to millions of viewers.
She told the perfect story around her product
and it resonated with millions of consumers.
Major celebrities started using Spanx and
endorsing it publicly:
With so much buzz, Sara clearly could have
raised boatloads of cash from top tier investors
with ease, but she didn’t, and that brings
me to Sara’s third key success factor: Sara
puts profitability first.
At every stage of Spanx growth, Sara has been
willing to get out of her comfort zone and
do things herself instead of paying others
and sacrificing profitability.
Instead of hiring a fashion design firm, she
designed the first version of Spanx herself.
Instead of paying a law firm to file her patent,
she went to the library and wrote it herself.
Instead of hiring sales people, she called
department stores herself.
Only when Spanx was making plenty of money
and could afford to hire people did she actually
expand her team.
But ultimately, it doesn’t matter how much
you’re willing to do yourself if your product
isn’t making enough money.
You need to make sure that the price your
customers pay for your product is significantly
higher than what it costs you to make it.
Many startup founders try not to think about
profitability early on, but Sara made sure
that each pair of Spanx made plenty of profit
for the business.
“A really good rule of thumb is five times
manufacturing cost, with packaging included.”
Good margins like that will give you the opportunity
to grow profitably without raising money,
and that’s exactly what Sara did.
She still owns 100% of Spanx and even though
the company hasn’t gone public, she’s
a billionaire.
But there’s one more important thing to
note about her model of profitable growth.
It’s really only an option if you commit
to it fully.
Once you raise money for your startup, your
investors are going to expect you to pursue
hypergrowth at all costs, and that often means
raising more money and eventually going public.
Some businesses are better suited for venture
capital funding than profitable growth from
day one, so really think about which model
makes sense for your business.
It can be hard to change horses midstream.
If you want to chat about startups, you can
always DM me on Twitter, and please check
out this recommended video, the YouTube algorithm
thinks you’ll really like it.